la vaccination désormais priorité
nationale c'était le sens du déplacement
des manuels macro hier dans le nord
le chef de l'état a notamment annoncé la
mise en place d'un nouveau numéro de
téléphone pour ceux qui n'ont pas encore
réussi à se faire vacciner et
l'accélération de la vaccination je cite
matin midi et soir florent clavel est
allé interroger les professionnels du
secteur alors at-on les moyens d'assurer
cette montée en puissance
la réponse dans ce reportage l'escale à
saint-cyr-sur-loire le gymnase robert
pouzioux à saint-avertin de futurs
vaccinodromes symbole de cette nouvelle
étape voulue par le président de la
république problème pas d'ouverture
avant trois semaines
alors comment tenir la promesse d'une
vaccination non stop
je vous appelle par rapport à la prise
de rendez vous pour la vaccination
co-lead chez nous les regards se
tournent du côté des pharmaciens après
les centres de vaccination puis les
médecins libéraux
ils vont pouvoir eux aussi commencer à
vacciner et ce dès demain nous avons
reçu deux flacons qui permettent de
vacciner 20 patients et éventuellement
peut-être une onzième doses par flacon
donc sûrement 22 22 patients 22 patients
par semaine soit près de 4000 pour
l'ensemble des pharmaciens
d'indre-et-loire accélération aussi dans
les six centres de vaccination du
département grâce à une hausse des
livraisons de files heures de leur côté
les médecins libéraux se tiennent prêts
à monter en puissance pour l'instant ici
on vaccine à peu près 300 personnes par
semaine donc avec encore une fois les
doses
nous avons comme les autres messages
analyse plus 200 doses pour les
professionnels de santé
on pourrait monter facilement ici à
700000 vaccination par semaine dès ce
week-end les plus de 70 ans vont pouvoir
commencer à se faire vacciner
du moins en théorie car à cette heure
chez nous se laisse os médecins
proposent encore des créneaux la préfète
d'indre et loire devrait en dire plus
demain